okay let's go to our caller from the
three one two area code caller from
three one two go ahead
oh hello David yeah this is angie from
chicago go ahead yeah my question was to
what what extent do you think people
actually adhere to their political
ideology rather right or left and what I
mean by that is there's a lot of issues
I think you could say are kind of should
be bipartisan or kind of blurry yeah and
sometimes I think people get caught up
in their own safe side of the political
spectrum because you know there's
obviously principles that they adhere to
and they'll put them on you decide
spectrum but to what extent do they
actually think they actually believe
that completely like there's certain
there must be some issues you don't
completely agree with that's on their
side of the spectrum but they still go
along with them because they're free
they're you know they're afraid of
dissent really kind of don't want to
disrupt the flow of politics so to works
and do you think people actually truly
adhere to their ideology completely yeah
I mean I think that they're what what
happens is that they're become these
kind of like packages of political good
positions that get wrapped up together
so as we've spoken about on the show if
you the line between being a devout
Christian and being against abortion for
example is pretty obvious to most people
the line between being a devout
Christian and being for really low taxes
on the rich is not quite so obvious so
what the connection ends up being is
that there's this like package of
political positions that gets wrapped
together and being against abortion and
being for low taxes on the rich or low
taxes for everybody tax cuts for the
rich and corporations whatever it gets
wrapped up even though maybe really it's
the abortion issue that actually speaks
to the values of like the ideological
Christian voter so I think to a great
extent there are lots of political
issues that opinion has become very very
much divided among partisan lines when
it actually doesn't it's not obvious
that it should be holding corporations
accountable for things that they do
there's no reason why that should be a
left-wing position that should be a
position for everybody who just believes
that we want to ensure that people are
doing the right thing and that
individual people who have little power
protected and so on and so forth but
it's become kind of a left-wing thing
you see that the you know pick whatever
whatever other example so you're you're
absolutely right in what you're
identifying there are lots of issues
where there should not actually be such
a partisan divide even basic level of
health care provided but by the
government when you ask that in a
nonpartisan way the majority of the
country agrees that the government
should provide a basic level of care to
everybody regardless of ability to pay
but then you have an entire political
party that has been for years and years
and years trying to repeal Obamacare and
which by the way is barely anything and
when it comes to providing care to
everybody and there's really no reason
for that so you've identified a massive
political issue in our country all right
I think you so much no problem
appreciate the call thank you and
apologies to everybody that we did not
get to we are out of time and there are
still 20 or so people holding but I do
promise we will take calls again and I
will try to take your call next time